the jurogan experience now
obviously the next course of progression
for a guy like you would be mma
yeah now i know that you had talked
about doing mma in the past but now it
seems like it's actually going to happen
yeah um so john doesn't want me to
compete in mma because he feels like
jiu jitsu is just about to break into
that next level of professional sports
uh so for me at least right now i feel
like
i need at least someone from my team to
be able to do the things that i'm doing
before i can kind of
move away from jiu jitsu into mma
because right now we have gary and mma
he's
carrying our flag our team's flag at mma
we have me the top of the heap in jiu
jitsu
so like if craig or nikki rod and my
brother
can start doing the things that i'm
doing and they went in atcc absolute
maybe or
they go out and they start beating and
submitting all the high level guys then
i feel like maybe i can leave
uh jiu jitsu because if i start fighting
mma i'm going to focus on mma
so i feel like if one of my teammates
can kind of take my place then i can
start moving into mma and then
and go from there so you look at it as a
you really do genuinely look at it as a
team effort you're not looking at just
as you're
as an individual most athletes are very
selfish and they just take take take
whereas we have we have a we have a very
great a very good team cohesion
and uh you know we're always looking out
for one another and
you know i find that that's the way that
people operate best
if you look at most teams it's basically
just a bunch of tough guys in a room who
trained together
who have no loyalty and if someone
offers them a better deal they're going
to go
somewhere else and train there um
whereas that's like whereas with us
we're very loyal to john and uh you know
everything that
everything that we do is the same like
my game is very similar to john's very
similar to gary's very similar to
craig's
we all are taught by john and we all
follow the same ideas and the same
philosophy of jiu jitsu
so the loyalty within the team is uh is
very strong
and uh you know i feel that it's all
it's always going to be a team effort um
you know without without john i wouldn't
be as good as i am without gary i
wouldn't be as good as i am without
nikki
it's the collaboration of minds in the
gym that that really pushes you forward
um so you know i feel like we're
different in that in that sense that
we're not a team that recruits people
we're a team that builds
that builds athletes from almost the
ground up like you see like a
you know a lot of the big mma teams uh
or even the big jutsu teams like autos
for example they recruit guys guys who
are already successful they recruit them
they give them a place to live
they give them a training program and
they they just recruit tough guys but if
you look at
a guy like andre and you look at his
black belts they all have
vastly different games conan's game is
different than andres hanger's game is
different than andres keenan's game is
different
than andre's and it's basically just a
team of recruited guys
who are a bunch of tough guys training
in the same room
whereas john we have a team of homegrown
guys who all do the same thing like they
all have discernible games
that all mimic what john teaches uh and
they just have
you know slight changes and variations
due to our physical attributes and and
and personalities now when you say you
think of it as a team you mean this is
taking it to a completely different
level because you're not
willing to progress your career outside
the realm of jiu jitsu until
someone else can carry the crown yes
that's that's next level commitment to
the team philosophy
yeah i mean like i said you have a guy
like john who's like the most selfless
person in the world like he shows up
every day and he gives you everything
like
you know i want i want what's best for
the team
uh even if it's not what's best for me
you know i wanna
i want what's what's best for for for
john's team
uh you know i want him to go down in
history as being the guy who had the
absolute best team in the world and
um you know right now you can make the
argument that sure you know gordon's the
best in the world
but the rest of the guys don't win as
much as him so i want to get those the
rest of the guys
on my team to to my level so that
you don't have the argument anymore of
sure gordon's good but he's the only one
who really wins when it counts
um you know i want i want to go into
adcc with my team and i want to win
every single division
so that would be insane that you know
that's not outside the realm of
possibility either that's what's crazy
yeah i mean next year we have gary might
cut to 66 kilos
so if gary's at 66 my brother will beat
77.
craig will be at 88 i'll be at 99 if
they let me do the division
and then nicky rod will be at 99 plus
what do you mean if they let you do the
division
so for adcc when you win the absolute
you go to the super fight
so this the the the super fight champion
fights the winner of the absolute
now i won the absolute last year so i'm
only supposed to have one fight
but i've requested to do the weight
division as well
because you normally would just do the
super fight but i want to do the super
fight and i also want to do my weight
division
so i have instead of having one match i
had five matches no one's ever asked to
do that
people have asked to do the absolute
before but the problem is
if i win the absolute and then
i win the super fight the super fight
winner's supposed to fight the absolute
winner so you can't fight yourself
right so it doesn't make sense to do the
super fight and the absolute but it does
make sense to the weight division and
the absolute
so if i if i if they let me do the
weight division i'll be the first person
in history to ever
to ever do the weight division plus the
super fight at the same time
wow now how is gary juggling training
for mma
and and jujitsu as well that guy is a
machine
he basically just he didn't he didn't do
less jiu jitsu
to do mma he just added mma on top of
the jiu-jitsu sessions
so he trains mma seven days a week and
he spars lightly seven days a week
and then he finishes that and right now
we don't have a gym set up in puerto
rico
so we're working around the schedule the
class schedule of the gym owner
so we have emma he does mma at nine and
then he
trains for like an hour spars then he
has like a 30 minute break
and then he does uh and then he does
jiu-jitsu at 11
and he just adds a session on so he does
mma jiu-jitsu seven days a week
and like within like two hours of each
other and when he's training mma he's
also grappling
yeah so he's grappling twice yeah most
most of the mma training
is shoot boxing is standing to take
downs because he's already
so good on the ground he needs to get he
needs to work and
fence wrestling and shoot boxing uh but
he definitely there definitely is some
grappling when he does mma so he
grapples and and spars
and then he pretty much goes right to
jiu jitsu and has to do that so
i mean that's definitely not an easy
thing to do and seven days a week is
definitely not an easy thing to do
and how is he doing in terms of striking
coaching like is he did he bring someone
with him to puerto rico was he using a
different person in new york what was he
doing he uses john
john is our striking coach really
telling you john knows
just as much about every martial art as
he does jiu jitsu like john
as our wrestling coach john's our
jiu-jitsu coach john's our striking
coach john's
mma coach like john coaches gary for
every aspect of mma while wrestling
everything
holy [ __ ] yeah
so he coaches him for kicking and
everything yeah dude
people notice about john john's first
martial art
was muay thai john did muay thai for
over a decade when he was growing up
and he studied all the best muay thai
guys i mean john knows
a lot about striking i mean he coach
like i said like people notice about
john they think he's just a leglock guy
or just the grappler like he coaches
gary and like gary's like
he's progressing fast and as far as the
striking's going
um he's only been striking for a year
and a half now and
he's uh you know he looks he looks
comfortable out there he does um
and uh that's shocking that he's only
been doing it a year and a half a year
and a half two years maybe
uh but yeah john's his coach john john
john coaches everything
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience